Filipinos back then had higher standard of government.
Back then, we had someone called a datu,...
...which are basically tribe chiefs and usually served his people well.
And unlike Spanish rulers, a datu can be legally impeached by the normal people.
Also to your surprise, we had a justice system back then.
It may not be as complicated as the justice system now, but it worked for them back then.
Next is life and culture.
Back then, we were self-sufficient in terms of food and other resources,...
...contrary to popular belief that we are always starving during those times.
We also had farming back then.
One notable farms we had during the pre-colonial period...
...and still around until now is the Banaue Rice Terraces located north of the country.
And one last thing I would like to mention is that...
...Magellan did not first discover the Philippines.
Way before he came to our shores on 1521,...
...we were already trading with Japan and China...
...several years before he discovered the Philippines,...
...so basically contrary to popular belief...
...about the Filipinos being jungle living savages during the pre-colonial times.
In reality, the Philippines during the pre-colonial days had a very advanced culture.
Basically anything that is contradictory to Spanish culture was considered barbaric.
The pre-colonial period finally came to an end...
...when the Philippines was discovered in the year 1521 and colonized on year 1565.
The Spaniards started Westernizing the Filipinos introducing Christianity...
...and traditional Filipino culture started to be replaced with Western culture.